uh Joe Biden is calling up his
presidential Protection Team over his
document drama meanwhile first lady Jill
Biden springing into action to Shield
her husband from reporters maybe some
supporters too asking whether he'll let
the FBI search his beach house for more
classified materials here's how it
played out
no I got it thank you
thank you yeah
[Laughter]
I love that costume
come on up Joe
no you're not going to dance believe me
we don't want to ruin the evening Mr
President
homes
wow
wow he looked he saw thought about it
and he was pushed forward Kareem
Jean-Pierre by the way ready to protect
the president by not answering any
questions or pretending as if there was
uh as pretending as if she couldn't
answer these questions but she is so bad
at her job she can't remember what other
officials say
if you do it inadvertently or you do it
and you really you realize you know you
don't have it secured in a locked bag or
you know you
you self-report
which is exactly what the president did
self-reported why do White House
officials insist that the president
self-reported the classified materials
if his lawyers initially called the
White House and not the justice
department I would refer you to the
White House Council but we heard from
this Podium the other day that President
Biden
self-reported the materials that's not
exactly what happened who did you hear
that from John Kirby well I would refer
you to the White House Council
so John Kirby answers the question and
uh she couldn't Jesse your thoughts
about how she's going to hold on to this
line still she probably thought when
Mike Pence came out and said I had some
paperwork this thing is done but it's
not I'm sorry I'm gonna have to refer to
the White House okay fine uh Jessica you
can only use that line in special
moments that can't be your answer for
every single question and that's why
Kirby's quality because Kirby has the
wherewithal to be able to dance and move
dip appropriately and talk like a human
being she can't talk like a human being
she talks like a binder and she's gonna
probably be fired or resign within the
next couple months I hope when I'm Joe's
age that Emma when I'm asked a tough
question right as I'm leaving a
restaurant
does the same thing with me it just kind
of ushers me out there gracefully
because man does Joe need a lot of help
uh judge at one point she has to get
brief div someone looking at her
briefings has to say hey wait a second
we got to give you something else to say
well
complicit in you know blocking the
information what what were they saying
however 68 straight days and not being
able to answer certain questions or
she's being she's inaccurately saying
you know only the White House can
counsel can answer this because there's
an investigation ongoing which we know
was inaccurate because during the Russia
collusion investigation they answered
all the time but the most important
thing is their own self-esteem I mean
how does the woman go out there does she
not know how embarrassing it is how she
looks ridiculous and not being able to
think she's blocking and tackling in
fact here's Ari Fleischer on that very
question you know he held that job
during uh right after leading up and
after 9 11. watch
her political and personal needs
dovetail perfectly with the stonewalling
needs of the Biden White House and
that's why she won't answer any
questions you know I could have played
that game in numerable times as press
secretary but you get to the point where
you say I've got an obligation I would
feel shamed if somebody else took to the
podium and answered the questions that
it was my job to answer
that's the point where's her self-esteem
is she happy just standing there and
blocking information or looking stupid
and Jessica it's very similar to the
attitude Senator Warner had yesterday it
was yesterday when he came out and said
not getting answers from the dni about
base about what was in those documents
is not something we're used to right
bipartisan outrage they do the same
thing well usually things happen when
there is bipartisan outrage show and you
can't just go to your corner and say
well my team is okay with this right key
members of the Biden team are not okay
with this obviously the Press is
frustrated the American public is
frustrated over 60 percent of Americans
have a problem them with what happened
that doesn't mean that they think that
Joe Biden is guilty of something
mischievous but they want they want
answers to this especially how it makes
it makes you think he's up to he's right
it leaves leaving doors open is a
problem and I think Dana last week
really hit the nail on the head where
she said to this point about Korean
Jean-Pierre
not being given enough information that
she needs to go in there and state of
the principal say to whomever she has to
you need to give me something to say or
I'm not doing it if you think John Kirby
is better than me then let John Kirby go
and do this he was up there to talk
about assistance to Ukraine and then had
a more open what felt more honest
conversation with the Press than she has
this entire time in it I'm not saying
that there aren't limitations being
placed on her but by the council's team
but she cannot effectively do her job
with the amount of information she's
been given we kind of agree on
everything before we get to how he's
handling the fact that he did have high
classified documents contrasted with
what Mike Pence said today he spoke
about what he what was found at his
place watch
during the closing days of the
administration when materials were boxed
and assembled some of which were shipped
to our personal residence mistakes were
made we were not aware of it at the time
until we did the review just a few short
weeks ago but I take full responsibility
for it
they shouldn't have been there
Jillian he didn't say no regrets and
there's no there there well it was
remarkable to see the former VP accept
responsibility and the reality that the
buck stops with him when the current
president and the former president have
not done that because everybody who
knows
um everybody who's ever had a security
clearance which itself included
um knows that the president not only has
a sacrosanct obligation to protect
classified information the nation's
Secrets above and beyond
average Americans but beyond all the
other security clearance holders as well
across the federal government I think
there's like almost a million of them
this is the person who's the
commander-in-chief this is the person
who is sending
um intelligence operatives overseas to
different countries uh in America's name
this is somebody who has American lives
depending on him it is not only a
question of whether the president and
former president can get away with this
it is a question of
is this a way to behave with Integrity
is this the way you want to protect the
Americans Jillian they were next to his
Corvette right I mean the safest place
they could be yeah you're right I think
you're being a little well one other
point I will tell you
um and I was saying yesterday in
Washington I was 23 years old when I got
my tssci security clearance to go work
at the National Security Council I tell
you this not because I'm like bragging
or something I tell you this because the
federal government is asking 23 year
olds to handle classified information
responsibly they can ask about it I have
a problem with the government trusting
you as a 23 year old right I might as
well
that could be a separate spin-off show
in fact you could bring that up and be a
new story I I will say this Donald Trump
had a very interesting way to handle it
uh it was my stuff and I Declassified it
I'd like to keep it hands off basically
uh and and uh Joe Biden said I left any
of my Corvette I have a great car hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube age and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else